ceausescus und herzlich willkommen aus
einer kartal in der nähe von köln
wir drehen heute wir drehen heute viele
viele viele neue folgen für anlockt acht
an der zahl tisch mit dabei sehr viele
sind mit dabei war unter anderem auch
irgendwann wir noch die gebiete
meinte
denk mal bewegen hatte
walter von schweinebäuche abonniert und
kann die von klein großer tv hd displays
ihr seht da unten wenn schon fleißig
durch die gegend geschoben
wir haben ja sage und schreibe hat im
fernsehen gesehen der durch die gegend
getragen wurde
schon vier gaming aufnahmen gemacht das
ist jetzt 15 uhr
wir sind heute seit circa 10 uhr hier
glaube ich haben schon fleißig fleißig
fleißig gedreht
9 uhr fällt aus ich hab ja schokolade
vier direkt reich sein allererstes
gemacht das ist dass minecraft man hier
einmal hier steht wie man die 1
minecraft wirst minecraft youtube money
zwei finger bild ja wir sind wie gesagt
auf der kartbahn nachdem ihr gatte eben
schon gaming aufgenommen haben kommen
jetzt die aufnahmen mit dem eigentlichen
card das alles ist wieder für den anlauf
channel den ja bestimmt schon mal
gesehen haben falls nicht ist er noch
mal eine beschreibung verlinkt ist und
channel auf dem wir mit verschiedenen
youtube an bisher mag sein ich immer
dabei action formate drehen über an zum
beispiel rohde laufzeit in österreich
heute kartfahren morgen passieren wieder
andere kranke dinge die wir hier drehen
werden in köln
das ist richtig heiß auf jeden fall
jetzt alles fleißig für die card fahrt
vorbereitet und ich bin schon sehr
gespannt mich hinter das steuer von
einem vorteil in der zeit von diesen
relativ schnell
viele leute jetzt haben auch das
kartfahren hinter uns gebracht sehen wir
das siegertreppchen werde allerdings
darauf stehen wird in der letztendlichen
anlockt folge ist natürlich unklar ich
werde es natürlich auch noch nicht
verraten denn die spannung soll bestehen
bleiben
martin verhältnis der junge kannibalin
zusammen mit max gefahren im team gerade
pause fit gemacht damit endet der dreh
für heute auch für uns wir fahren jetzt
gleich noch selbst ein bisschen carlo
zum zeitvertreib morgen geht's auch
wieder richtig runter stehen alle
möglichen aktivitäten an übermorgen auch
noch mal einer sagen was ich verrückt
mit mainz wird knights leute alles klar
altlasten costa 28
tag zwei kolonien köln
aber sind wir hier eigentlich mehr oder
weniger auf dem schrottplatz
und machen jetzt heute hier irgendwas
mit ferngesteuerten autos glaube ich was
genau sie dadurch in der folge aber ich
meinte ich das hier mal an das sieht
wirklich schon sehr creepy auch noch so
weiter steht
so darf jetzt schon einen kleinen
vorgeschmack auf das bekommen was ihrem
unlock videos sehen werdet hallo also
der platz hier ist ziemlich abgefahren
wenn man sie mal so umschauen mega viel
schrott hier zum beispiel ich das mal an
dass es mit das friedlichste gute
freundin von mir hat sich über die jahre
leider nicht so gut gehalten aber ist
immer noch ein guter mensch
persönlichkeit ist alles was zählt so
wie sie auf jeden fall erstmal fertig
mit dem dreh heute nachmittag und abend
folgt noch ein zweiter morgen noch ein
letzter haben wir acht weitere folgen
anlockt für euch wird auf jeden fall
wieder sehr gespannt wie die werden und
ja ich glaube jetzt haben wir
mittagspause in the sky zwei stunden
später
so leute die mittagspause ist vorbei und
ihr seht ein gast hallo
moneyou unterhält wird aufgebaut denn
wie fahre jetzt damit aber die frage ist
was passiert diesem tag sind also max
hat in zusammenarbeit mit
allein im alter alleine mit adel getauft
weil ich wusste dass six in den späten
kinners leute die zweite location vom
zweiten tag hat irgend einer von euch
das einordnen ich bezweifle stark auf
jeden fall habe man zwar nicht zu knapp
die haut box geben wir darin euro gelder
von ihr okay leute die zeit ist
verflogen
und auch das zweite set am zweiten
drehtag ist fertig abgewickelt jetzt
geht es zurück ins hotel morgen der
dritte und letzte drehtag an und ich
verabschiede mich schon mal für heute ja
lasst mal 20.000 like sonst kann nicht
nicht weiterreden okay die dritte und
damit herzlich willkommen zum dritten
und letzten drehtag leute eigentlich
sollten heute um 38 auf ständiger
eigentlich 38 aufstellen ich habe
gestern bis 5 uhr noch videos
geschnitten und mails gemacht meine so
zu max und mich bitte an druck ich bitte
an weil ich sonst ich wache morgens auf
39 also ich bin zurzeit zu der wir
abfahren sollen aufgewacht gerufen
ich hab sie haben miteinander geredet
irgendwas erzählt 0 erinnern so fertig
war hat mir genau das gleiche gesagt er
soll ja ich habe praktisch als
vorausgesagt und vergebe sein
es ist eine stunde dazwischen alles
vergessen und ihr habt das dazu schon
heute morgen wir sind dem letzten dreh
auf einem
schauplatz mal gucken was jetzt passiert
so der leute hat um 14 uhr
schätzungsweise geld ist jetzt 17 uhr
wir haben jetzt hier was gegessen die
andere sind schon wieder weg den sich
nach gemacht hätten hat man im ganzen
haus auf die skyline von köln wir sind
jetzt auch ganz offiziell durch mit dem
letzten drehtag für erdgas ich mache
jetzt hier noch ein anderes video fertig
wie gesagt
basta das war's so weit von diesem blog
und wenn der blog online kommt ganz
wichtig ist der teaser für die neue
benchmark staffel anlockt da für ein jk
c't der ist man in der beschreibung
verlinkt wie immer unbedingt abchecken
das projekt hat noch deutlich mehr
aufmerksamkeit verdient also bis jetzt
bekommt und das wasser hat mir auch
reinmacht gut und